President Barack Obama met President Dilma Rousseff at the White House Tuesday...
...to unveil the series of new agreements including many that aim to make the planet healthier.
It speaks to our clear-cut commitment of protecting the environment...
...and also efforts to make sure the global temperature...
...will not go up beyond two degrees as agreed.
As countries that are as vast as continents,...
...we have to set this very important greenhouse gas emissions target.
Following progress during my trips to China and India,...
...this shows that the world's major economies can begin to transcend some of the old divides...
...and work together to confront the common challenge that we face,...
...something that we have to work on for future generations.